welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of all the
Easter eggs and details you missed in
Marvel's Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania this breakdown is brought to
you by our good neighbors over at State
Farm okay let's begin quantumania's
Marvel Studios Fanfare includes for the
first time in MCU villain he remains
from the Loki finale added to the top of
the a in Marvel as this movie places his
throne room atop an a-shaped Tower and
he has a history of dominating other
countless Avengers and in the post
credit scene there is a glimpse of his
corporate variant Mr Griffin who I
believe currently sits atop Avengers
Tower renamed King Tower then again he
remains was relatively an MCU hero
compared to his variant Kang the
Conqueror in this film this prologue
scene shows his arrival in the quantum
realm when he was banished by the Kang
Dynasty for starting the same
multiversal war that he remains alluded
to not every version of me
was so pure of heart new worlds meant
only one thing new lands to be conquered
the peace between reality erupted each
variant fighting to preserve their
universe and annihilate the others you
can see three pieces breaking off of
Kang's ship as it arrives in this
atmosphere perhaps representing the
three kings who led his betrayal and
sabotaged his ship there may actually be
a connection between the three time
Keepers in the mysterious fourth broken
time people statue a statue that
represents perhaps this exiled King now
remember Jenna Van Dyne had been stuck
in the quantum realm since she shrunk
between atoms to disable a rogue ICBM in
1987. now to clear up this frequently
Asked question Janet aged normally over
the 30 years in the quantum realm while
Scott time dilated aging only five hours
over five years of our time because
Scott fell into a Time Vortex While
Janet did not didn't just stayed in the
normal Quantum realm that entire time
remember Janet's line in the 2018 film's
post-credits scene indicated that time
vortexes were separate things within
that broader Quantum realm and don't get
sucked in into a Time Vortex we won't be
able to save you now it isn't specified
but the camera does linger on one of
those big vortexes in the sky and that
might actually be one of the time
vortexes that Scott slipped through and
one of the ones that the Avengers later
navigated to go back in time in Avengers
end game but this opening gives us a
scenario in which the roots of Phase 5
and the Multiverse Saga begin with two
old school characters Jenna bandine wasp
was one of the original Avengers in the
60s comics and Kang was one of the OG
Avengers villains the time traveling
villain from the 1960s Comics who was
later retconned to be the same entity as
several other time-centric villains
immortus valorama touch Scarlet
Centurion Victor timely even the hero
iron lad we're gonna meet all of them
pretty soon Kang and Janet saved each
other and we don't see Kang again 4-0
another 46 minutes despite everyone in
the movie talking about him in every
scene that's okay again we're gonna
spend a lot of time with this guy going
forward Scott Lang's opening montage is
set to John Sebastian's theme song for
the sitcom Welcome Back Cotter welcome
back welcome back welcome back a kind of
call back to the 2018 Ant-Man the WASP
having an opening Montage set to come
bonded happy a theme song for another
sitcom The Partridge Family Scott's
opening narration references time
traveling with Captain America and
endgame and now that didn't make sense
though in Loki we learned that was
something the king variant he remains
wanted them to do what they did was
supposed to happen you escaping was not
FBI agent Jimmy Wu Randall Park makes
the Cameo he and Scott finally getting
that lunch date yeah how you were
inviting me somewhere like a party or
like dinner or something I don't know I
thought you were planned the evening no
I meant to like arrest you I will arrest
you later again take it easy okay
did you want to grab dinner or something
I mean because I'm free yeah come on I
love how Scott does some sleight of hand
to conjure the credit card something
that Jimmy will was fascinated and Scott
doing and Hitman the wasp and we saw one
division how Jimmy picked up Scott's
close-up magic hobby Scott gets toasted
by YouTuber Ryan bagar and his wife
Muriel Scott I've actually guessed it
with Ryan on his channel Watcher I love
that channel I love the whole team over
there and this makes me so close to
being MCU Cannon Kevin just called me
you know it would make my life Scott's
old basket Robin's boss Dale returns to
the 2015 film now he Awards Scott
employee of the century using his old
company photo and he kept Scott's pink
apron and his name tag Jack which in the
2015 film Paul red picked out to shout
out his son jack and this goofy award is
also kind of a running gag with Cassie
giving Scott a world's greatest grandma
trophy in the previous film now Quantum
media is the 31st movie in the MCU which
is a nice bit of coincidence with the 31
Flavors of our beloved Baskin Robbins
Scott visits Bridge donuts with all the
donuts overpriced at 350 per very
typical of San Francisco and all the
different Donuts are themed around San
Francisco things the Embarcadero Summer
of Love Hate Presidio Pier 39 Golden
Gate and the Candlestick a detail that I
screwed up and when I trailer breakdown
like I'm sorry I I now know the Giants
don't currently play there I've only
lived in the city for a year please
don't kick me out of it I like the parks
now the cafe owner is played by actor
Reuben rabassa who actually played a
balloon vendor Mr cardazzo in Agents of
Shield Season 2 Episode 12 and a
hilarious character in I think you
should leave uh any other ideas stinky
what here he says thank you Spiderman
which is a completely Fair mix-up
considering after that memory white from
Doctor Strange no one remember said
Spider-Man is Peter Parker hope Van Dyne
now runs the Pim Van Dyne Foundation to
use pen particles for humanitarian
efforts reversing deforestation
expanding public housing food production
meanwhile Scott parades on his book tour
which was actually teased in Black
Panther wakanda forever and in Ms Marvel
when we saw Scott was doing a lot of
press tours like his appearance on the
this powered Life podcast Scott has to
pick up Cassie from jail Cassie now
played by Catherine Newton jail is where
Scott began his journey in the 2015 film
but Cassie is really taken off of both
ant-mans including Hank Pym he kept a
shrunken Soviet tank on his keychain and
now we see she shrunk a cop car on the
drive home Cassie says she protested the
city clearing a homeless encampment of
people who had lost their homes in the
blip referring to the people who dusted
back to find their homes occupied
creating a giant housing crisis Cassie
also says
a guy dressed like a bee tried to kill
me in my room when I was six
I've never had
enough of course setting up the return
of Darren cross in this movie as Modoc
Scott plays a clip from his audiobook
and in that moment all I could think was
how did the Hulk turn me into a baby
will I be a baby forever am I the hoax
baby little after that a raccoon from
space showed up I don't think he knew my
name I was just happy to meet a raccoon
who could talk yes obviously more nods
to end game of course median rocket and
that interesting moment where their
failed time travel experiments resulted
in Scott being stuck in the body of a
baby which reminds us of how the
Avengers accidentally invented a kind of
immortality or at least slow aging which
does become important in this movie when
they're super intelligent ants age a
thousand years in a single day over
dinner Cassie reminds Scott that he got
in trouble for getting back at Vista
Court that was a company that Scott used
to work for the company that was
screwing over its customers Scott tried
to get back at them and then ended up in
prison over it she also brings up how
Scott went to Germany to fight Captain
America in Civil War Scott corrects are
saying that he fought with cap alongside
cap since he was on team cap Hank uses
old school pit particles to enlarge a
pizza and in his ear we see that he has
a hearing aid setting up his frequency
and tangling with these ants throughout
the movie Peyton Reed confirmed that
this pizza enlargement is a nod to the
pizza hydration scene and Back to the
Future Part Two And when we enter their
basement lab right away are a ton of
visual Clues pointing to Cassie and Hank
having geeked out over both ants and
Technology Cassie's Quantum satellite
ice is a silver and bronze color like a
vintage stereo reflecting Hank's design
influence and Scott sees their huge ant
farm right away and how all the ants
inside have helmets and have already
built a pretty complex society there the
display screen on the other side of the
room has a 3D image of an ant on it and
all over the table are textbooks about
ants Janet is super worried you know how
dangerous the quantum realm is we all do
Mom nobody's going to the quantum realm
so Janet went from being pretty okay
with Scott going into the quantum realm
to collect Quantum healing particles at
the end of the 2018 film to now be
completely terrified that Cassie is even
communicating with a Quantum realm so
what changed well maybe Janet was fine
with risky Scott going down there for
just a few seconds to a specific region
of the quantum realm that Jana could
locate a place that in her gears on the
run from Kang she hid in the surrealist
rural parts away from the civilization
but it's also possible that the Avengers
having gotten away with time travel via
the quantum Realms since then has
reminded Janet that Quantum realm-based
timeline manipulation is a real thing
and that Kang is still a real threat
down there and they shouldn't risk
re-entry again they shouldn't tempt fate
because as Tony Stark said in endgame
unless your time intends to match back
so the device activates on its own but
we later learned it was Modoc hijacking
it and the whole family gets sucked in
Scott bumps into the ant farm right away
proving that these ants got sucked in
too and that they're gonna come back
later the family gets separated and
Scott slaps on the chest piece of his
now compared to the last time we saw him
in end game his suit the opening
sequence of this movie has a different
chess piece and that's because this is a
form of portable nanotech that contains
the entire suit inside showing how Scott
has upgraded to something closer to
Stark Tech and after giant Scott catches
his daughter I love how sheep roof she
already knows how to work this in her
own suit by pressing the button on
Scott's glove to shrink them back down
what Cassidy thinks is the sun behind
Scott has stuttered movement and they
realize it's actually a predator Scott
enlarges to take it out and then pisses
off a paramecium looking creature and
they're saved by the Freedom Fighters
meanwhile Janet explains to Hank how
there's a whole civilization and
ecosystem down here saying you weren't
able to look deep enough not through the
void in subatomica there are worlds
worlds and worlds it's a place beyond
time and space and she says it's the
secret Universe beneath ours she's
referring to that moment when Hank and
Janet left the quantum realm in the 2018
film and Peyton Reed hid a city in the
background that area with the chaotic
visuals must be what Janet was referring
to by the void even though in Loki the
void is a completely different place
where he remains banishes things that he
prunes and then she drops the word
subatomica now in the Marvel Comics
subatomica is the name of the solar
system that's contained within the
microverse that contains all the various
different planets that you can visit
down there you can actually read a lot
more about subatomica and its various
appearances in the Marvel Comics over on
the fandom
fandom Scott and Cassie are taken to the
freedom fighter camp where they have to
drink the Ooze from Feb voiced by David
dust malcian who played Kurt in the
previous films William Jackson Harper
plays the telepath quas great casting as
Chidi from the good place the guy in an
afterlife burden with knowing too much
Katie O'Brien plays their leader gentura
Janet takes them to a dune region where
she gets a manta ray like Mount that she
telepathically communicates with in the
2018 film there was a deleted scene in
which Janet communicates with a Quantum
realm creature passing through we stake
no claim
go
in peace and when they soar across the
quantum realm on this thing's back they
briefly spot a Quantum knots Outpost
which has a Kang mural on it Janet Lee
tank and hope to the city of Axia I saw
the Tomic Universe this changes
everything we know about life Evolution
our place in the Galaxy holy
like that looks like broccoli
yeah broccoli man is voiced by Graham
Fox who is the onset reader for Crow and
eternals and they meet up with Janet's
Old Flame krylar now Lord krylar played
by Bill Murray now the comics krylar is
a sort of one and done character from
the planet Kai in the microverse who
shows up just in one comic issue
Incredible Hulk 156. similarly this car
alarm doesn't last too long in this
movie before Hank Pym enlarges the squid
creature delicacy that for whatever
reason doesn't eat krylar really let him
off easy there krylo reveals that Kang
had sent Modoc mechanized organism
designed only for killing to hunt Scott
and Cassie in the freedom fighter camp
now in the comics Modoc is an aimed
technician George Tarleton who gets
mutated by The Cosmic Cube but Marvel
Studios here has retcon Modoc to be
Darren cross Corey stole's villain
yellowjacket from the 2015 film his body
parts disproportionately shrunk after he
was zipped down to the quantum realm and
as we see the uncanniest valley in this
whole uncanny valley of a film a montage
flashes back to Darren in the 2015 film
his defeat and now picks back up with
his disfigured form of the quantum realm
and how Kang restored his body in its
creepy little butt becomes the source of
agree for the rest of the film and by
the way a great resource to learn about
Modoc is again that Marvel database from
our friends at fandom which also curates
every single one of modoc's known comic
appearances so you can go read all of
them I do love how he has a heart rate
monitor on his chest that later flat
lines when he dies and he has a crystal
on his forehead that he used to fire
Beam at Scott and attain them for Kang
he remains used eliaith as his lap dog
Kang uses Modoc Janet finally tells hope
and Hank her history with Kang she says
that Kang's ship could travel the
Multiverse and Hank asks the Multiverse
as an alternate Dimensions parallel
realities and Janet says I didn't
believe it at first but it's real just
as we theorized so Hank and Janet having
theorized about the Multiverse back in
the 80s makes him predecessors to
another couple Wanda and vision having
some Multiverse Pillow Talk in the past
what do you know about the Multiverse
this had his theories he believed it was
real and dangerous now much like how
Scott hope and Cassie shrink and grow to
a variety of sizes people's car
insurance comes in all sizes too a
driver with their first hatchback could
have very different needs than a Hank
Pym level experience driver with a sweet
vintage ride State Farm of experience in
Industry leadership make them the best
choice for your insurance needs whatever
they might be with over 19 000 agents
State Farm is the good neighbor that
shows up for their customers so whether
you're re-watching quantumania for the
third time or scrubbing through every
previous Marvel trailer for hints that
Kang was there all along you'll know
State Farm is there too just me am I the
only one who's looking forward to doing
that call or go to statefarm.com to get
a quote today Janet recounts how after
they saved each other she and Kang
agreed to help each other rebuild and
reactivate the Multiverse engine core of
this ship now we don't know how many of
the other kangs have this kind of
Technology but we have to assume that
none of them do or they all do now that
he remains is out of the picture but
they have a kind of truce where they're
able to check each other's infinite
power over the time stream a kind of
mutually assured destruction making this
Kang Kang the Conqueror the Rogue state
of them all the Kim Jong Kang the one
who didn't play by the rules now Janet
says his ship was neurokinetic connected
to his thoughts so when she touched it
she saw his mind and felt what he had
done she says entire worlds entire
timeline's gone like they never existed
this sequence uses the same sacred
timeline imagery from Loki but it shows
the actions of this Kang the Conqueror
tearing it apart while we see Kang
within a single timeline blasting
innocence who flee from him he's causing
so many Branch timelines on individual
scales that the timeline as a whole
cannot take it so it's not just murder
it's load-bearing murders that destroy
the fabric of that timeline and I love
how we see kangs and the lines on his
face Illuminating as he Slaughters these
people lines precisely where the scars
are on his cheeks now and I'll go into
what those scars are in next week's Deep
dive into this film on the other channel
so just another reminder to subscribe
Janet waking up from this nightmare
pauses in fear and Kang is able to see
it in her eyes and she knows who he is
she asks who is Kang the first time we
hear the word Kang in the MCU and Kang
hearing this question knows that he has
hurt so many people in his life he just
knows what it looks like when the
person's staring back at him knows what
kind of monster he is and I love that he
frames his master plan in just a single
word win what is Kang's plan to win
Janet has to disable score or by
enlarging it Beyond use with Pim disks
so she had these on her the entire time
she was in the quantum realm these are
probably rainy day pin discs that she
was hoping she'd be able to use to
escape the quantum realm but this task
is more important Kang must be trapped
even if it means entombing herself with
him and again this justifies why in the
2018 film Hank found Janet far away from
the city in the distance she had to
Exile herself in the far borders of the
quantum realm to stay hidden from Kang
and that explains why in the 2015
Ant-Man Scott saw her Shadow projected
on the other side of the border of the
quantum realm she was on the far border
of it to get as far away from Kang as
possible meanwhile Kang in prison
introduces himself to Scott and retracts
his mask giving us a close-up look at
that neurokinetic overlay and how it
clings to his skin perfectly but as it
retracts you can notice briefly diagonal
reinforcement lines across his cheeks
becoming visible and the lights on the
side of his helmet dim Kang says he has
killed Avengers before for the second
time in this movie Scott is confused
with the wrong Avenger you're not the
one with the hammer Thor we get confused
a lot similar body types yeah Kang has
specifically killed Thor which I
speculated a new Rockstar's video might
have been done right before Thor sparked
Vision to light since vision and his
Multiverse mind would pose potentially a
pretty major threat to Kang in another
timeline Kang explains that he knows how
all of time ends saying me a lot of me
they exiled me down here they're afraid
of me which might sound pretty familiar
to what his variant he remains says them
Loki if you think um
evil well just wait
till you meet bye variance it just
sounds like all the gangs are really
just afraid of each other while he
remains was extremely animated jumping
in and out of his Jets chair Majors
performances came the Conqueror is far
more rigid Regal what the actor
described as no moves wasted he'd
tortures Scott and Cassidy with just a
flick of a finger a gesture that he
repeats consistently to swat them down
and make commands throughout this movie
but throughout the film you can see his
rage simmering beneath the surface
rising and Rising until it all just
explodes in the final battle
Scott agrees to help Kang shrink the
core so that Kang won't hurt Cassie and
Kang opens the portal to the site and
from here Scott dives into the
probability storm and begins splitting
into variants which modok describes as
Schrodinger's Fox and Scott is a cat
referring to Urban Schrodinger's thought
experiment to describe the theoretical
existence of a Multiverse within an
unobserved system Schrodinger's cat was
first referenced in the MCU back on Eric
selvic's chalkboard and Thor the Dark
World this concept was also described by
Bill Foster in the 2018 film the object
in question would be both in and out of
phase with multiple parallel realities
this chord is essentially a far more
advanced form of Tony Stark's Quantum
navigator that they used in the quantum
realm and end game it's just on a far
more controlled scale and produced from
a self-perpetuating energy source and
seems like inside this core is a kind of
Nexus hub for different multiversal
realities to spawn from the bands of the
score have writing on them a language
based on circles which you can see in
other parts of the quantum realm this
might be a language that Kang uses and
enforces throughout the realm now one of
Scott's variants is himself if he never
became an adventure and say the Baskin
Robbins off screen another one if you
listen closely asks it for ice cream
when one of the Scots sizes up he
unravels into ribbons which looks a lot
like what Wanda maximoff did to read
Richards we don't know what's really
going on here why this happens but it
might just be some Divine multiversal
law that says when you stray too far
from your hive of variance you get like
self-provened out of existence and from
here this scene is just smartly shot by
having all the other Scott variant's
helmet up out of fear but our Scott
stays unhelmeted which is both the
practical way to follow him in the scene
and a way of showing his courage and
determination to save Cassie but really
it's Cassie who saves Scott all the
Scots by uniting this whole Hive behind
their constant and after shrinking the
core back down Kang meets the rest of
the gang and tells hope hello Jelly Bean
jelly bean what's Janet's nickname for
hope this is his creepy way of
indicating that he knows her Kang takes
the core swats away Scott and hope and
takes Janet back to his Fortress where
he has this fascinating conversation
with her he projects the sacred timeline
around the room starting with just a
ring in his hand I saw the chaos
spreading across realities universe is
colliding endless incursions I saw the
Multiverse and it was dying all because
of them he projects that one ring over
another ring with branches between the
Rings veering toward each other and
colliding with little flashes these
represent incursions and after these
incursions happen those branches stay
there just kind of sad broken ends
showing how one of the universes won
that incursion the other one didn't and
let this ugly scar behind remember when
he remains first revealed the Multiverse
and his origin story he depicted it as
one ring floating atop another ring so I
love how this movie is really building
on that visual language and now we see
how the sacred timelines eruption upon
still be killing he remains in the Loki
finale affects another sacred timeline
that event as well as Peter Parker and
Doctor Strange's spell going awry and
Doctor Stranger won a maximoff
dreamwalking and Multiverse of Madness
are all examples of these kind of
incursions and how one by one they
represent a crack in the dam leading to
the overall death of the Multiverse
what's interesting is this Kang doesn't
blame the Avengers for it he looks down
on the Avengers like they're helpless
children who don't know what they're
doing instead he blames the other kings
in the dynasty for their childish medley
childish behaviors beneath kangs and he
views himself as the adult in the room
who believes that order is detained only
by conquering as he says burning the
broken world and building a new one he
says all the suffering will be worth it
defending himself saying I have lost you
have no idea what I have lost and I will
burn them out of time for what they've
done to me so think about this when we
see Kang in this movie vaporizing people
in his mind he is burning them out of
time like cauterizing a wound leaving a
scar sending a message with that Scar
and yes we are left with the mystery of
what Kang lost one theory is that he's
doing all this to win back his long-lost
love of ravona rensslayer but I don't
know based on Kang later pummeline Scott
after Scott decided to leave his
daughter behind and instead into himself
with Kang I have to wonder if Kang might
himself have a daughter we don't know
about I don't know maybe Ravon is
actually his daughter maybe Miss minutes
is his daughter's soul I don't know my
mind is running away with me Hank
meanwhile was saved by his Ant Farm the
ant time dilated a thousand years in a
single day meaning they must have
slipped into a Time Vortex and in that
time they built a socialistic
technocratic Society I think we always
forget that the best parts of these
Ant-Man movies are the ants these ants
neutralize Kang's advantage of
Technology hundreds of years in the
future because Kang's chosen system of
governance is an archaic military
dictatorship he doesn't know how to play
with others Kang mobilizes his Fortress
to depart the quantum realm with his
entire Army he declares today we conquer
eternity and the dynasty of Kings before
Cassie Cuts him off but conquer
eternity interesting choice of words
considering the character of Eternity as
of Thor love and thunder did have a
physical form in the MCU and we're not
exactly sure where eternity is after it
seemed to transform into mistress love
there may not be an eternity to conquer
which is an interesting concept because
John at the majors partially basis
character on Alexander the Great what do
they say about Alexander the Great
Alexander wept for there were no worlds
left to conquer and yes of course Kang
also mentions his dynasty whom we meet
in the post-credits scene and will be
the Kings The Avengers have to face in
Avengers King Dynasty in 2025. Giants
got attacks King's Fortress this is the
largest he has grown yet in the 2018
film film he bragged to Bill Foster that
his record then was 65 feet or 19.8
meters which is roughly how big he gets
in the San Francisco Bay an Avengers end
game that wide shot of all the portals
opening up giant Scott when you compare
his height to a nearby human giant Scott
is roughly 19 times as tall as that
human and if you were to put that human
at six feet because those look like the
wakandans you know the mountain tribe
they're pretty tall that would make
giant Scott an end game around 114 feet
tall or 37.4 meters but now based on
this one shot where giant Scott Stomps
on the quantum knots those Quantum knots
I would say are about 25 of the scale of
that human next to his foot in end game
which means that Scott here must be
around at least four times taller than
he was in endgame well over 450 feet
tall now or over 137 meters our man is
roughly the height of a small skyscraper
and yes when Scott Stomps on king's
forces it is mirror how Kang will later
stomp on his helmet as if of course
trying to crush an ant Scott picks up a
disc shaped piece of a building and uses
it as a shield a shield that he later
wedges into Kang's Rings much like his
hero Captain America would bring in full
circle with his reference membership on
team cap he cannonballs into the Rings
and breaks them now think about this
Kang could have used that Multiverse
core to power his ship chair alone and
escape the quantum realm without going
to all this trouble the reason he fails
really is because he got greedy he
wanted to bring his entire Fortress his
entire fleet with him to wage war on all
the kings because he insisted on
bringing all of his stuff with him he
gave Scott and the others enough time to
stop him though In fairness decaying You
could argue that he felt that he needed
all this backup because the moment he
escaped in the quantum realm you'd have
the full might of the Kang Dynasty on
him this is all a way of saying it's
hard being Kang we get this little
moment where giant Scott celebrates with
giant Cassie and what I love about this
shot is that it was likely one of the
easier VFX shots to do since both actors
are the same size but I do like how they
slowed down their speech and their
movement just a little bit but either
way father and daughter are finally on
the same level they're finally talking
slow enough to listen to and understand
each other Cassie says she's hungry and
craves a lime to which Scott says yeah
Citrus it's weird this calls back the
running joke of Scott always wanting
orange slices after he goes big does
anyone have any orange slices Scott even
had had orange slices ready to go when
Hawkeye came back from the baseball
glove trial in Avengers end game and so
Kang finally allowing his rage to boil
over floats down to the battle on a disc
and vaporizes everyone in sight I love
how his neurokinetic armor automatically
shifts up his arm and over his shoulders
to just get out of the way and give his
arms greater flexibility the Freedom
Fighters despite making some gains when
beb used his holes to Kirby some Quantum
knots Kang repels them he kills Solomon
and tutorial is forced to retreat and we
briefly see one of the sentient
buildings holding the other as it dies
in its arms but facing down Kang is
Scott hope and Cassie where Cassie
finally Masters a jump Tab and Scott
grows large enough to slam Kang against
the wall saying you sucked up before
Kang blasts him off remember Kang
Nathaniel Richards is the son of a
bloodline that traces back to Reed
Richards Mr Fantastic so Kang might have
cut off Scott's sentence to avoid having
to think about his lineage But
ultimately Hank's aunts saved the day
swarming Kang and Darren takes cass's
advice to stop being a dick love the
look of disgust and anger Kang is Modoc
in this moment this is a conqueror who
hates being betrayed and modog turns
Kang's shield from Kang's color blue to
modox color fuchsia allowing the ants to
pick apart Kang's armor and carry him
away they watch modok die his heart rate
monitor turning red and flatlining Janet
uses the quantum chord to open a portal
home but Scott notices Kang approaching
and pushes Cassie in order to stay
behind and fight Kang just to keep him
in the quantum realm now think about
this it's not really explained how Kang
got away from the ants but now I'm
pretty worried about the ants and even
more impressed with Kang for defeating
an advanced technocratic Society with
the willpower of one conqueror I don't
know maybe made side deals with some of
the top ant lieutenants Lieutenant to
turn on the others or maybe brainwash
them with some fascist talking points
that socialism doesn't work I don't know
I'm impressed Kang and Scott fight one
on one and I do like it when an epic
third act battle boils down to just a
simple fist fight or sword duel Kang's
armor is broken off to expose his arm
John of the majors gets to show off some
of that physique and come off like a
physically imposing Force Scott is
outmatched but he's able to hang in
there because he's not trying to win I
don't have to win
we perfect
hope returns and helps Scott destroy the
core with red and blue pin particles
creating a Vortex pushing Kang into that
Vortex and shrinking him out of sight we
gotta assume he's not dead he is Darren
cross went through this same process
realistically keng's probably stuck in
an endless probability storm down there
where unlike Scott it's gonna be really
hard for Kang to cooperate with his
variants so when he does figure it out
ah look out we got Secret Wars coming
meanwhile Cassie uses her Quantum realm
telescope to locate the last note spot
where the portal was and reopens it I
didn't know what Communicator could do
that and I thought her Communicator only
portaled them in before because Modoc
hijacked it the logic's kind of fuzzy
but in my opinion what saves it is that
this film's epilogue doesn't really
leave things all neatly tied up for
Scott anyway he remains haunted by the
consequences of defeating Kang to
conqueror fearing the Kang Dynasty now a
dynasty that is coming based on the
post-credits scene introducing us to
Rama Tut and mortis thousands of other
kings now on a mission to stop the
Avengers from continuing to tamper with
the Multiverse the second post-credit
seems even scarier in some ways
introducing us to Victor timely a king
variant 1901 who I explained the
post-credits scene might have inspired
Howard Stark but as he goes back through
its routine Scott's eyes sing to linger
on people wearing the same shade of
bright purple with purple balloons at
Cassie's party a green cake purple and
green the colors of Kang's armor yes I
know it sounds crazy but this is where
Scott's brain is right now he's paranoid
he's losing it and there is a deeper
significance to Scott's unresolved
paranoia that I will explore in next
week's quantumania Deep dive but a few
things to note about Scott's changed
reality on the wall by the sidewalk of
his morning walk there is now graffiti
of an Ant-Man helmet with a heart around
it happy Valentine's Scott and Reuben
now knows his name but still there's a
lingering creepiness to Scott going back
through his Loop of his life as if
nothing has changed like his life is an
episode of a sitcom from which he cannot
Escape he is the comedian sitcom
starving welcome back welcome back
welcome back welcome back to a narrative
Loop written for him by Architects
controlling every aspect of his life
Architects were now thrilled that he did
away with their pesky Exile and yes I
did break down this movie's post-credit
scenes and the video for everything else
I bet I brought it up in the quantum
media live stream that I did over on our
new channel the Deep dive which is now
live with launch Day videos that you are
gonna love please subscribe to it and
you can support our growing Network by
getting something at nerdriot.shop like
this rain Eternal shirt or maybe
something from the deep dive collection
and thanks to our friends at State Farm
for sponsoring this breakdown and I'm
indicted to do this all video like a
good neighbor State Farm is there call
or go to statefarm.com to get a quote
today you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]